bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne à la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi de modernisation de l'agriculture
il s'agit de la quatrième loi agricole
en 10 ans
objectif de ce texte préparer la france
à la réforme de la pac la politique
agricole commune qui est prévue pour
2013 mais aussi assurer des revenus
décents aux agriculteurs il faut dire
que les revenus agricoles ont chuté de
34% en 2009
le gouvernement entend donc mettre en
place une véritable politique publique
et de l'alimentation
c'est l'objet du titre premier dont je
vous propose de suivre tout de suite la
discussion bonne science à tous alors la
séance et reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture et de la pêche dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement 522 rectifié au
sein de l'article 1er et j'ai cinq
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
alors qu'est-ce qui nous présente c'est
françoise laborde qui nous présente cet
amendement 522 rectifié ministre nous
voulons rédigé ainsi la linea 17 le
respect des terroirs et le lien entre le
consommateur et le producteur par le
développement de filières courtes et
l'amélioration de la proximité
géographique entre producteurs et
transformateurs
en effet les consommateurs mais aussi
les restaurateurs artisans et
commerçants de bouche sont les
véritables prescripteurs de
l'agriculture car ce sont eux qui
consomment et valorise ses productions
un lien étroit doit par conséquent les
unir aux producteurs pour que les
produits agricoles correspondent aux
attentes de ses clients
or on constate aujourd'hui une évidente
distension de ce lit
elle découle notamment de l'urbanisation
des fortes évolutions connues par les
exploitations agricoles
il convient donc de veiller à préserver
et à renforcer ce lien
dans cet objectif le développement des
circuits courts et la proximité sur un
même territoire de l'ensemble des
acteurs d'un processus d'élaboration
apparaissent comme des outils efficaces
le consommateur gagnera en confiance
envers les produits qu'ils achètent
ayant plus facilement connaissance de
leurs origines et de leurs modes de
transformation
l'objet de cet amendement est donc
d'inscrire plus précisément cet enjeu
dans la politique de l'alimentation et
il est vraiment proposé d'ajouter à
l'alinéa les termes le lien entre le
consommateur et le producteur
cette proximité suppose notamment le
maintien d'équipements indispensables
comme les abattoirs
merci bien le 204 rectifié n'est pas
défendu le 328 c'est gérard le cam qu'il
présente sur le président monsieur
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
il est ici question d'un amendement en
faveur des territoires de montagne où je
me fais le porte parole de madame david
en particulier dans le souci de
valoriser les circuits courts et
terroirs cet amendement se porte se
propose de compléter la politique
nationale de l'alimentation d'un champ
d'actions supplémentaires afin de
renforcer le lien entre les produits
agroalimentaires et leur territoire on
peut se féliciter de l'adoption d'un
amendement en commission visant à
intégrer dans l'action du pn a le
respect des territoires par le
développement des filières courtes
toutefois la valorisation des circuits
courts passe aussi par l'amélioration de
la proximité géographique entre
producteurs et transformateurs
c'est d'autant plus important dans les
territoires de montagne ou au delà de la
reconnaissance de la spécificité
montagne c'est toute une politique de
produits qu'il s'agit de développer
cette politique doit passer en partie
par la reconnaissance de nouveaux labels
exigeant que le produit montagne
présente une typicité qui le distingue
de biens analogue produits dans d'autres
parties du territoire mais également par
l'aide à la commercialisation en
circuits courts
il ne suffit pas de reconnaître la
spécificité de l'agriculture de montagne
encore faut-il en tirer les conséquences
pratiques pour organiser réellement
l'aide propres à ces filières par
ailleurs cet amendement permettra sans
nul doute une meilleure visibilité pour
le consommateur qui aura connaissance de
l'origine et des modes de transformation
des produits qu'ils achètent à la
lumière ces éléments je vous demande
chers collègues de bien de vouloir
adopter cet amendement
merci le 227 c'est toujours vous gérard
lockel alors 227 donc ce projet de loi
de modernisation de l'agriculture de la
pêche dans sa version déposée sur le
bureau de notre assemblée ne faisait pas
mention au départ des circuits courts
pourtant la réflexion a largement fait
son chemin à travers les exigences du
grenelle et le rapport que vous avez
initié sur le sujet monsieur le ministre
nous sommes donc satisfaits que le
rapporteur est jugé utile de faire
entrer les circuits courts dans
l'article premier du projet de loi
cependant
soulignons que cette modification a été
fait au minimum alors que des
propositions concrètes existent dans ce
contexte de volonté commune de
développement de circuits courts volonté
plus ou moins ambitieuse
nous tenons à attirer l'attention sur la
question des abattoirs en effet les
abattoirs constitue un élément essentiel
de la filière viande
or ils ferment les uns après les autres
si bien que dans certaines régions comme
dans le nord les bêtes sont abattues en
belgique est l'exemple qui était donné
hier sur l'allemagne je crois que
c'était en commission qui n'a que trois
abattoirs à mon avis n'est sans doute
pas le modèle idéal à copier cette
situation s'explique de plusieurs façons
on sait et c'est normal que les
abattoirs doivent respecter les
exigences sanitaires et
environnementales en vigueur en
particulier tous les règlements du
parlement européen et du conseil du 29
avril 2004 qui prévoit toutes les règles
spécifiques d'hygiène applicables aux
denrées alimentaires d'origine animale à
tous les échelons de la filière les
investissements nécessaires pour la mise
aux normes sanitaires peuvent être
financés dans le cadre du fonds européen
agricole pour le développement rural
feader au niveau régional seulement cela
n'est souvent pas suffisant et si les
investisseurs publics interviennent les
conditions d'éligibilité sont largement
réduit les contraintes sanitaires delà
de la concurrence libre et non faussée
sont là mais elle ne saurait justifier
la fermeture massive des sites
nous demandons que l'objectif de
maintien des abattoirs soit inscrit dans
la loi et que le gouvernement travaille
à trouver des solutions qui permettent à
ces structures d'exister ce faisant on
satisferait des exigences
environnementales mais également
sociales et surtout le maintien d'une
diversité de production sur le
territoire qui risque de disparaître par
l'éloignement même de ces structures
d'abattage vous remercie merci le 441
n'est pas défendu il tombe alors
monsieur le rapporteur gérard césar
votre avis sur les trois amendements qui
restent
oui merci monsieur le président à ce qui
concerne 522 c est donc les filières
courtes ont précisément pour objet de
rapprocher les producteurs les
consommateurs les filières courtes se
conçoivent toujours essentiellement pour
les produits peu ou pas transformé et je
trouve que ce remaniement n'est pas
adapté donc aux textes et se donne un
avis défavorable à ce qui concerne
l'amendement 328 ces mêmes
avis défavorable à ce qui concerne mes
papiers 227 c'est un avis d'effacer le
sait les abattoirs
c'est sûr que nous souhaitons les uns
les autres d'avoir des abattoirs à
proximité mais il faut que ces abattoirs
d'abord correspondre aux normes
européennes premièrement soit mis aux
normes
deuxièmement que ces abattoirs est une
dimension suffisante pour avoir un prix
davantage la taxe d'abattage le plus
équilibré possible car les abattoirs
entre se font quand même une certaine
concurrence
donc je trouve que le maintien des
abattoirs à proximité élevage ça n'a
rien à faire avec ce texte c'est un avis
défavorable 1 ce qui concerne c'est tout
mais c'est ouvrir le ministre alors
trois avis défavorable de la commission
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs se sont
également trois avis défavorable sur des
trois amendements pour deux raisons
différentes la première sur les circuits
courts
nous sommes que la rédaction du texte de
la commission est suffisamment explicite
alors mentionnant le développement des
circuits courts et pas ailleurs dans la
suite du texte d'autres dispositions
sont envisagées pour améliorer les
circuits courts sur les abattoirs
d'abord une précision pour monsieur le
cam c'est moi-même qui effectivement
cité l'exemple des trois abattoirs
allemands tone flash et verburg qui à
eux seuls consentent l'abattage de 54%
des porcs allemands
je les cite est pour expliquer les
écarts de compétitivité je n'ai pas cité
comme modèle
je pense pas que ce soit un modèle à
suivre pour la france cela étant
l'installation des abattoirs ne peut pas
se faire sous forme de plan national ce
que votre amendement pourrait amener à
recréer puisque ce serait contraire à la
directive services donc rien interdit
ensuite de développer des abattoirs ici
ou là mais sans plan national qui serait
contraire à la directive services c'est
pour cela que nous émettons un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
je profite de ce président d'avoir la
parole pour vous prier de bien vouloir
m'excuser je devrais ma santé à partir
de 16h40 pour l'entretien que pendant la
pub lic haut rhin avec le commissaire
européen
la culture dacian ciolos je serai
remplacé durant cette courte période
avantageusement par henri de raincourt
ça va nous le connaissons bien
allez je vais soumettre ces trois
amendements qui on tue des avis
défavorables de la commission et du
gouvernement à l'approbation notre
assemblée alors sur 522 et qui fait y at
il une demande de d'explications de vote
d'atari goulet vous avez la parole oui
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
étions il ya quelques semaines
à cambremer sur les journées de la
hausse et ce texte n'est pas évidemment
en liaison avec la hausse et ni les
problèmes mais la problématique des aoc
mais nous avons à ce moment-là discuter
de la délocalisation possible de
l'agriculture et d'un certain nombre de
productions et il a été rappelé monsieur
vinet était d'ailleurs présent le lien
extrêmement important qu'il y avait
entre la consommation et les territoires
les aoc est en moyen de fixer évidemment
les productions et moi je veux dire que
j'ai été très interpellé sur cette
notion de délocalisation de
l'agriculture qui a l'air tout à fait
curieuse mais en réalité
après avoir entendu les explications des
experts qui étaient là gg j'ai tout à
fait compris de quoi il s'agit chez je
crois que l'amendement de madame laborde
de fortassin colin et du groupe et rds a
au moins le mérite de donner de
l'importance à ce lien entre les
productions et les terroirs et moi je
comprends que de toute façon dans le
dans le fatras de cet article 1er où on
y retrouve finalement plus grand chose
ça changerait pas grand chose non plus
de rajouter ce lien avec les ter entre
les territoires les terroirs et les
produits en tous les cas moi je le
voterai s'il est maintenu bien alors
monsieur bérit débat oui je voudrais
également dire que cet amendement est
particulièrement intéressant dans la
mesure où effectivement il maintient ce
lien comme vient de le dire notre
collègue entre le territoire le respect
du terroir et le consommateur
on vous renvoyez monsieur le ministre et
monsieur le rapporteur à l'amendement
suivant qui dit que c'est assez
explicite mais il n'est pas inutile de
le rappeler
on peut effectivement avoir moi je le
connais bien dans dans son département à
faire référence à des produits du
terroir notamment dans une
transformation par exemple et
ne pas avoir effectivement ce lien de
proximité entre ce qui est produit avec
le territoire dont il ya quelquefois
tromperie du consommateur c'est assez
ambigu et je pense que les précisions
qui sont apportées par le groupe rdse me
semble des précisions importantes qui
peuvent figurer dans la loi
merci alors il n'y a plus de demandes de
parole je mêle 522 rectifié de françoise
laborde à l'approbation notre assemblée
quai pour l'adopter
alors 15 qui est contre alors égalité
des voix
il est rejeté le 328 gérard le cam deux
avis défavorables qui est pour l'adopter
alors 3
504 9 9 et 4 13 13 et 15 voilà il y
avait deux autres noms on a bien compté
alors le 328 excusez moi tu es pour
girard c'est celui de gérard le cam qui
est contre il n'est pas adopté 227 c'est
exactement le même mot qui est pour la 2
qui est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté on continue trois amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune alors le 205 rectifié n'est pas
soutenue à monsieur bernard émond est là
exact
excusez moi je vous en prie monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre le
présent amendement vise à compléter la
politique nationale de l'alimentation
pour que soient systématiquement prises
en compte les spécificités territoriales
et notamment celle des territoires de
montagne
merci ensuite le 329 gérard le cam
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres collègues
il s'agit par cet amendement d'attribuer
au programme national pour
l'alimentation une action spécifique
pour adapter les normes à certains
territoires notamment ceux de montagne à
nouveau que je défends au nom de madame
david afin de tenir compte de leurs
spécificités conformément à l'article 8
de la loi du 9 janvier 1985
en effet la montagne est un ensemble de
territoires qui du fait de ses
caractéristiques géographiques et
climatiques propres appelle des mesures
spécifiques ainsi en raison des surcoûts
de production de l'agriculture de
montagne liées aux difficultés de
production exacerbée dans un
environnement montagnards utilisions
d'équipement utilisation d'équipements
spécialisés qui sont souvent onéreux une
application uniforme et stricto sensu
des normes compromettrait la viabilité
économique des exploitations agricoles
de ces territoires
aussi nous semble important que le pn à
adapter les mesures normatif aux
spécificités territoriales de la
montagne bien que comme l'a indiqué le
rapporteur le pma est davantage un outil
d'animation de la politique de
l'alimentation qu'un instrument
réglementaire il nous semble toutefois
qu'il peut contribuer à reconnaître la
spécificité de la montagne en impulsant
une politique de l'alimentation qui
distingue les produits agricoles en
fonction de leur lieu de production en
évitant une application homogène des
normes cela permettrait de compenser le
handicap montagne et donc valoriser les
produits issus de ces territoires
c'est pourquoi je vous demande chers
collègues de bien vouloir l'adopter
je ne sais pas si ça s'adaptera aux
montagnes bretonne qui commence est un
peu raboté aujourd'hui merci merci
françoise laborde vous nous présenter le
574 rectifier alors je vais très brève
puisque d'autres collègues ont bien
défendu et puisqu'il avait déposé le
même amendement je considère qu'il est
défendu
oh merci monsieur rapporteur votre
opinion sur ces trois amendements
je vais faire comme françoise laborde je
vais dire que le même argumentaire
etienne pour les trois amendements
donc je préciserai quand même pour nos
collègues que la prise en compte des
spécificités des territoires de montagne
est nécessaire cependant je suis pas
certain que l'adaptation des normes et
réglementations de va s'appliquer les
montagnes puisse trouver sa place dans
le pena noms qui me semble que les
dispositifs particuliers pour le mental
relève de textes spécifiques
donc c'est un vide est favorable si au
moins je peux proposer le retrait qui
est une mesure déjà compensatoires et
pour les deux autres c'est le même
argument donc le même avis bien alors
qu'air berlin vraiment vous avez été
sollicité pour en retrait éventuel je
suis compréhensif monsieur le président
je m'en remets à la sagesse du
rapporteur 5 rectifier et retiré je vais
soumettre les deux autres amendements à
l'approbation notre assemblée
il n'y a pas de demande d'explication de
votre alors bernadette bourzai vous avez
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues les
explications qui ont été données par
monsieur le cam su se suffisent à
elles-mêmes et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement que nous prenions en
compte
mieux que cela n'a été fait jusqu'à
présent les spécificités de la montagne
les conditions de production sont
infiniment plus difficile et plus rude
dans les zones de montagne que
et je ne parle pas des mandats d'arrêt
je parle de la moyenne montagne dans
laquelle j'habite mais aussi des
pyrénées des alpes des vosges et nous
savons que pour produire dans ces
conditions il faut des méthodes
différentes et il faut pouvoir tirer
profit de produits différents qui sont
des produits de qualité donc il faut que
nous puissions au travers de ce texte
labellisé produits de montagne les
produits les productions qui sont faites
et qui permettent dans des conditions
qui peuvent être de pluriactivité ou qui
sont simplement des production initiale
de faire vivre des exploitations dans
ces zones où l' équilibre agro sylvo
pastorale est difficile à maintenir
et c'est pourquoi je regrette que dans
le vote précédent
on est éliminés comme ça la question des
abattoirs
quant à produire des produits de qualité
sans pouvoir les transformer sur place
sans pouvoir les valoriser sur place il
me semble c'est une grande erreur parce
que d'une part ça ne permet pas de
retenir de valeur ajoutée sur les
territoires de montagne mais de surcroît
ça coûte
au bilan carbone ça veut dire qu'on va à
des centaines de kilomètres transformer
des produits qu'ils perdront d'ailleurs
de leur étiquette entre guillemets
puisque on le sait bien les étiquetages
sont encore très mal assuré et la
qualité ne sera pas reconnue donc je
pense qu'il faut que nous ayons un
réflexe qui d'ailleurs n'est pas un dû
puisqu'il est prévu dans la loi montagne
de 1985 qui affirme que les spécificités
de la montagne doivent être prises en
compte dans les législations
merci alors je soumets ces deux
amendements votre approbation qui est
pour les adopter ils sont identiques
à part dont celui d'istres je vais
rapidement monsieur le président juge
pour apporter une précision
bien entendu il faut tenir compte des
spécificités de la montagne je rappelle
que nous avons maintenu la débilité
compensatrice des handicaps naturels
il ya toute une réglementation
européenne sur ce sujet là aussi bien
pour le développement de territoire que
pour les spécifications alimentaire donc
tout cela est l'objet de la
réglementation communautaire si dans la
loi
nous rajoutons des obligations
supplémentaires sur ce sujet là nous
serons en infraction avec la législation
communautaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle tout en partageant l'objectif
nous estimons que l'amendement n'est pas
souhaitable
voilà donc nous avons deux avis
défavorables sur deux amendements
identiques
il n'y a pas d'explications de vote ça a
été fait qui est pour adopter ces deux
amendements identiques qui est contre
ils ne sont pas adoptées alors qui est
ce qui nous présente le 94
c'est jacques gillot d'accord cet
amendement va dans le sens des propos
que vous avez tenus monsieur le ministre
lorsque vous allez précisé que vous ne
souhaitiez pas une alimentation
uniformiser reconnaissions monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en fonction
des régions
les traditions les traditions culinaires
sont bien différentes
nous pensions qu'il faut valoriser ces
différences nous proposons non que cet
amendement
les actions du programme national pour
l'alimentation encourage davantage la
valorisation le cas de notre patrimoine
alimentaire et culinaire pour chaque
région française
cette diversité locale doit tête doit
non seulement être préservée mais
véritablement encourager sous
différentes formes qu'il s'agisse pas
exemples d'actions de communication de
formation encore de la valorisation des
circuits courts de distribution
cette valorisation locale est très
important pour les régions d'outre-mer
et pour toutes les productions le cas
l'an merci bien quel est l'avis du
rapporteur
l'amendement de monsieur larcher visa
modifie la décision que et surtout la
rédaction qui avait été adopté par la
commission
elle est née à 18 cet alinéa prévoit que
dans le cadre du plan national paul
imitations sont menées des actions en
faveur du patrimoine alimentaire et
culinaire français cette définition
paraît suffisamment large et elle avait
même reçu un large consensus à réunion
de la commission pour ne pas le remettre
en cause
il me semble que la valorisation des
productions agricoles et la cuisine
ultra marines pourraient tout à fait
intervenir dans le cadre de la rédaction
actuelle
je vais en profiter pour saluer même du
mal qui est ici un humain qui a été
chargé d'une mission sur la gastronomie
française et lui dire merci pour tout le
travail qu'elle fait j'en profite de ce
moment là pour lui dire toute mon amitié
que tout notre soutien pour la
gastronomie française
avis défavorable mon cher collègue alors
à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
président de raincourt où monsieur est
épais non mes honoraires président
n'aurait oui je suis président cet
amendement qui est président présentée
par monsieur larcher et le groupe je
veux dire comme le rapporteur à
l'instant que pour le gouvernement
nous considérons que la rédaction qui a
été adopté par la commission couvre déjà
l'objet de cet amendement et que d'autre
part le patrimoine français s'appuie sur
la richesse et la diversité des
patrimoines régionaux qu'il faut
valoriser au niveau local mais bien
entendu aussi au niveau national et
international et donc en fait nous
considérons que la rédaction proposée
par l'amendement en fait réduire est
donc la portée du projet du gouvernement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
émettons un avis défavorable
alors y at il une explication de vote
qui est pour adopter
didier guillaume vous avez la parole si
son président monsieur le ministre on
peut comprendre l'argument du
gouvernement et du rapporteur
mais nous l'analysons à l'envers c'est à
dire que reconnaissons quand même et je
crois qu'on va tous être d'accord que si
nous sommes tous dans la république
française y compris lorsque l'on est en
guadeloupe ou en martinique il y a quand
même une spécificité pour ces régions là
et d'ailleurs on a vu ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques mois la l'engagement du
président de la république et la volonté
de faire un plan spécifique pour pour
l'outre-mer alors lorsqu'on voit lorsque
dans le texte
il est marqué patrimoine français ça va
bien mais si on rajoute des régions
françaises
c'est pas en aucun cas un handicap ou un
bémol c'est au contraire un dièse un
forte un allegro parce qu'on va parler
de toutes les régions françaises
donc c'est pas uniquement sémantique ou
des ou des phrases mais reconnaissant
quand même
et là je m'adresse aux rapporteurs c'est
vrai que la commission a adopté
unanimement donc que nous revendiquons
totalement cette adoption mais il
expertises de nos collègues des de nos
collègues d'outre-mer reconnaissance du
camp ce qui me concerne est bien
meilleur que moi même donc l'idée
c'était de renforcer un peu ce ce sujet
de parler de toutes les régions
françaises
j'allais dire y compris l'outre-mer
merci alors catherine du bain vous avez
la parole maintenant sénatrice ces
présidents sur ministre mes chers
collègues oui d'abord merci gérard césar
monsieur rapporteurs des propos que vous
avez tenus c'est vrai que je voulais
prendre la parole par rapport au dossier
de l'unesco qui est une formidable
opportunité pour la france de pouvoir
promouvoir notre patrimoine culinaire et
gastronomique et donc je voulais
rappeler que nous avons ce dossier en
cours et que nous aurons donc la réponse
de l'unesco en moi 2 au mois de
septembre 2010 en ce qui concerne les
propos qui ont été tenus par abc
guillaume je voudrais dire que je suis
assez d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
avec l'amendement qui étaient déposés
ceci dit je comprends tout à fait ce que
la commission a pu déterminer et je me
rangerai donc à son avis alors je
rappelle que nous avons néanmoins deux
avis défavorable sur cet amendement il
ya plus de demandes d'explications de
vote qui est pour l'adopter
qui est contre
il n'est pas adoptée chameau vais vous
nous présenter le 30 rectifié bis oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il vous est
proposé avec mes collègues d'insérer un
nouvel alinéa s'il est rédigé après
l'alena 10,8
tous produits commercialisés sur le
territoire national doit porter bien
lisible pour le consommateur
l'indication du pays d'où vient le
produit proposé à la vente s'il est
vendu en l'état ou du pays d'origine des
matières premières ayant été utilisées
pour sa fabrication
s'il s'agit d'un produit ayant fait
l'objet d'une transformation
industrielle ainsi que de l'indication
du pays où il a été fabriqué ce présence
minnis on sait que la mondialisation
fait en sorte que beaucoup de produits
sont importés de l'extérieur nous avons
et c'est normal on a beaucoup parlé du
consommateur on a parlé de
l'alimentation le texte l'indiquent et
toulon a reconnu que c'est essentiel
nous avons beaucoup de rigueur dans
notre pays et pour la fabrication de
chacun des produits
il ya peut-être quelques fois un peu
moins de rigueur
à l'extérieur il faut donc que le
consommateur puisse se retrouver et
qu'il achète les choses en connaissance
de cause et c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai déposé cet amendement c'est à
travers un étiquetage très précis
indiquant l'origine du produit
la manière dont il a été fabriqué que le
consommateur peut s'y retrouver
voilà l'objet de cet amendement cosigné
par sloan de mes collègues gérard césar
monsieur à porter oui merci monsieur le
président effectivement les tic age
origins a fait l'objet et fait toujours
l'objet de leva sa réflexion et surtout
dans le cas de monsieur le ministre vous
savez bien
dans le cadre de la mission jégo sur le
made in french ans et concerne les
produits alimentaires
la commission a adopté un article 1er
bis qui apporte une préoccupation à une
réponse sur tout achat relevé ces
l'étiquetage de l'origine ou la vente
décide
et et cet étiquetage sera donc dans la
loi et sera donc obligatoire
donc il me semble charles revêt mon cher
collègue co-rapporteur que votre
amendement est satisfait et donc je vous
demande le retrait sinon je serai
malheureusement obligé de donner un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre oui monsieur le
président je pense que la préoccupation
de monsieur charles revêt et tout à fait
dignes d'intérêt pas du tout c'est
justement parce qu'elle est très digne
d'intérêt que c'est important de
rappeler ce qui a déjà été évoqué sur ce
sujet hier deux fois à l'occasion de
l'examen d'un amendement 241 qui était
présenté par gérard le cam certains ses
collègues et d'autre part comme le
rapporteur pierre excellemment de le
dire à l'instant c'est pris en compte
dans le texte actuel qui résulte des
travaux de la commission mais je me
permet d'aller plus loin en disant que
en plus ce serait contraire aux
exigences communautaires et pourrait
être attaqué par la cour européenne
comme cela a déjà été le cas en grèce et
en italie
et donc je pense que ça en fait si
l'objet est bon sa rédaction
fragiliserait le texte du gouvernement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je me
permets de me tourner avec empressement
et chaleur vers monsieur revêt pour lui
suggérer de prendre la meilleure
position qui soit c'est à dire de
retirer son amendement alors chaland
vers à alain vasselle des rameaux avant
monsieur le président en vous remerciant
sans doute que le charles revêtira la
moment sous la pression amicale du
ministre et de
et du rapporteur moi je comprends très
bien la réglementation qui vient de
développer par le monsieur le ministre
il y adhèrent qui ne fait que reprendre
celle qui nous a été développée pas plus
tard que la nuit dernière par bruno le
maire sur des amendements qui
s'apparente à celui déposé par d'autres
collègues
alors il est vrai que monsieur le
rapporteur il est prévu dans l'article
1er bis une disposition qui devrait être
de nature à satisfaire notre collègue
charles regret si ce n'est que vous
voulez c'est la faculté de fer tendu
chaleureux vraie demande à ce que ça
devienne une obligation ce soit fait
d'un côté vous êtes dans le peu et
charles devrait dit doit bon or c'est
parce que l'on dit doigt qu'on s'oppose
à des dispositions d'ordre européens et
j'ai entendu de la bouche du ministre
hier que tout ce qui avait un caractère
contraignant que nous pourrions
introduire dans la loi se heurtait à des
dispositions européennes et le ministre
a pris l'engagement devant nous enfin
tout du moins il nous a dit que son
combat consistait à faire évoluer la
réglementation européenne de telle
manière à ce que ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui soit partie intégrées donc
de des dispositions européennes
donc il s'agit de faire confiance au
gouvernement pour aller dans cette
direction parce que moi je reste comme
beaucoup dubitatif quand le pouvoir
contraignant des dispositions que nous
introduisons dans la loi j'espère que ce
ne sera pas
que ce ne seront pas des coups d'épée
dans l'eau que nous sommes en train donc
de réaliser si par aventure le ministre
ne restez pas dégager une majorité au
niveau européen pour que ce que nous
souhaitons soit introduit dans les
dispositions européennes
donc qu'est ce qu'on a à faire
aujourd'hui on va pas mettre le
gouvernement en difficulté
nous ne pouvons que faire confiance en
l'avenir et la seule question que je
pourrais me poser comment peut-on
comment peut-on aider le gouvernement
pour qu'il obtienne de la part des
autres pays européens
que deviennent une réalité ce que nous
souhaitons nous mêmes ici sinon à quoi
servons-nous chez nous à quoi servons
nous en fait tout repose sur la faculté
et la possibilité du gouvernement
d'arriver à convaincre ses collègues de
faire ce que nous souhaitons faire donc
je ne saurai ce matin donc c'est tout
crise oblige à rien d'autre à dire
je laisse à mon collègue chambre revêt
le soin de prendre la décision
je vais laisser néanmoins la parole à
des interviews
oui merci monsieur le président à ce
moment du débat je crois qu'il faut
vraiment être très précis moi je
soutiens cet amendement de monsieur
revêt pour plusieurs choses
non seulement il peut bien sûr
s'applique et surtout produits
commercialisés sur le territoire
national mais même en plus il peut nous
permettre de nous garantir contre une
forme de jal et disons le de publicité
je fais pas dire mensongère mais qui
parfois s'appuie sur une image très
positive d'une région et qui sous
prétexte de dire produit ici ou produits
là n'est en réalité que l' amalgame d'un
certain nombre de produits transformés
dans cette région et qui viennent
d'ailleurs et je crois que là on a un
véritable souci
alors moi ce que je pose comme question
monsieur le rapporteur c'est ce que vous
avez évoqué hier
est-ce que ce que l'on a accepté va
changer ses pratiques et va obliger les
industriels qui ont ces pratiques
eh bien allez changer sinon nous serions
nous tout à fait prêts à voter cet
amendement
la travée goulet oui oui monsieur le
président henri sioniste mes chers
collègues nous avons eu ce débat hier
c'est vrai mais je crois que là la
sphère de l'étiquetage est quand même
extrêmement importante pour le pour le
consommateur dans son ensemble on a
exactement le même problème dans le cas
du plfss où on veut indiquer des notions
de produits pas gras pas trop salée
passe aussi pas cela les calories qu'on
va finir à la fois par avoir la
nécessité d'avoir les étiquettes les
plus complètes possibles et ensuite
d'avoir des produits périmés quand on
aura fini de lire les étiquettes
donc moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait
une réflexion complète sur l'étiquetage
des produits qu'on souhaite et je crois
que cette affaire est extrêmement
importante je suis pas très favorable au
goût de travail dans l'ensemble mais je
pense qu'on pourra avoir une vraie
réflexion parce que ce dos ce dossier là
est vraiment trop important pour le
consommateur et nous nous avons le
problème en normandie
nous avons les camembert de normandie
qui sont faits avec du lait qui viennent
de n'importe où y compris de d'ailleurs
que de normandiez qui utilise comme
vient de le dire madame hervio la
qualité du produit et l'image de ce
camembert de normandie qui en fait peut
être très bien fait du lait chinois
donc moi je crois que l'amendement il
est tout à fait intéressant il a
peut-être pas sa place aujourd'hui
ici dans ce contexte mais je crois qu'il
faudrait vraiment que dans le cadre de
l' alimentation puisse avoir une vraie
réflexion sur l'étiquetage qui sera
aussi utile dans le cadre du plfss
s et de tout ce qu'on essaye de faire
pour protéger à la fois les enfants et
les adultes d'une malle bout de
l'obésité d'acheter des produits dont on
ne maîtrise absolument pas la
composition
si paul raul c'est vrai que depuis hier
soir on discute de ce problème qui est
certes difficile mais qui est quand même
lié à une politique de l'union
européenne qui va contre la qualité des
produits
c'est à dire qu'on clair on veut
uniformiser l'ensemble de la production
et à partir de là on voit bien que on
veut supprimer par exemple les crues 1
les fromages au lait cru
un sous prétexte 2 et que donc les
spécificités régionales finissent par
disparaître et deuxième élément on va
bien l'idéologie de l'europe c'est
toujours de devoir derrière notre
volonté de défendre nos produits locaux
une forme de dépôts de protectionnisme
déguisé et on n'entend que ça on nous
fait manger à des pommes par exemple
golden venant de hollande qui sont
évidemment pas cher mais qui n'ont aucun
goût et nous nos producteurs qui font
des jeunes à golts et autres un des
produits de qualité ils ont du mal à les
écouler et en plus lorsque dans nos
cantines au restaurant scolaire ont fait
un appel d'offres on a du mal à
introduire dans la charte de la commande
de l'appel d'offres que on veut
effectivement des produits bien locaux
parce que aussitôt il ya une armée de
fonctionnaires zélés qui viennent vous
dire que l'appel d'offres il est mal
rédigé
et et qui ne met pas librement en
concurrence des produits venant
d'ailleurs
donc il ya la fois c'est vrai la
philosophie de l'europe qui voit tout de
suite des formes de protectionnisme
larvé et puis ensuite il ya aussi chez
nous la concurrence et les prix qui est
toujours en train ne sucent et nous le
suspecté de vouloir tricher en quelque
sorte et de vouloir faire du commerce
avec le producteur local comme si
c'était forcément mal comme si c'était
forcément mal alors à partir de là on a
du mal c'est vrai à faire en sorte que
les produits de nos propres régions on
puisse les retrouver dans l'assiette de
nos enfants
si gérard ces armes se rapportant aux
avez la parole de la commission
il est bien dit sans préjudice des
dispositions spécifiques relatives aux
morts de délégations de l'origine et
d'aidé alimentaire
l'indication du pays d'origine pétrole
est obligatoire pour les produits
agricoles alimentaires et les produits
la mer est abruti ou transformées
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que tout
le monde a intérêt à ce que le produit a
été étiqueté cetc dans le sens de du
consommateur de bien connaître la
provenance est aussi la qualité de ce
produit mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
grâce à ce texte
on peut généraliser pour ceux qui le
souhaitent donc l'étiquetage de tous les
produits écoles ça me paraît une mesure
très importante et intéressante
voilà monsieur le président oui je vais
te revient peu dans le débat mais
c'était un sujet essentiel au niveau du
débat de la commission chocolat
l'amendement de charles revêt qui parle
de l'étiquetage quand tu veux pas me
mettre à la place du ministre je passe
cette ambition mais je me souviens bien
des débats que nous avons eus
mes chers collègues sur l'étiquetage des
produits et la réponse du ministre
aujourd'hui pourquoi on accepte et
peut-être rendu obligatoire c'est pas en
conformité au niveau aux directives
européennes
ministre est engagé justement à faire
évoluer ses directives européennes
il faut convaincre les autres pays de
l'est les développer il ya un autre
aspect que le ministre s'est engagé à
prendre en compte aussi c'est les
indications géographiques protégées
il faut y être très attentif s'était dit
une indication géographique protégée
dans le droit communautaire
elle permet de prendre en compte la
nature d'un produit local mais suffit et
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure que le
produit soit transformée dans la région
pour bénéficier du de de l'appellation
régionale et pour moi c'est une anomalie
ce quand on parle d'une indication
géographique protégée
elle s'appuie sur une zone et je
répèterai en séance publique et ça
concerne même le ministre de raincourt
le charolais on peut parler du charolais
de bourgogne et ça c'est une véritable à
des questions géographique protégée nous
avons même du mal à faire reconnaître
cette indication géographique protégée
je l'évoqué au niveau 2 du ministère
et pourtant d'un bien dans cette espèce
là est par contre on à la moutarde de
dijon où il ya une partie de la boutade
qui vient du canada s'est uni gp donc je
pense qu'au niveau européen
il y a vraiment eu une discussion à
avoir
je pense qu'on peut s'appuyer sur notre
ministre de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture et de la pêche pour
convaincre nouveau nous convenons que
son homologue européen et avec jean
bizet et que la commission des affaires
européennes nous avons mis en place un
groupe de travail sur sûrement sur les
perspectives d'évolution de la politique
agricole commune et ça c'est un des
éléments qu'il faut faire valoir aux
autres pays pour le mettre en avant les
véritables indication géographique
protégée et même par la suite
rendre obligatoire peut-être
l'identification des produits pour
répondre à la préoccupation de charles
revêt mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui il a
satisfaction
le rapporteur l'a dit le ministre l'a
dit par rapport aux textes en vigueur et
pour répondre alain vasselle
on peut pas déborder le texte en vigueur
aujourd'hui au niveau européen et je
pense qu'on peut compter sur
l'engagement de notre ministre alors
charles roven on en arrive finalement à
vous monsieur le président j'ai entendu
l'appel de notre sympathique ministre
que nous connaissons bien la seule
interrogation que je fais et je vais
longtemps gelé entendu l'interrogation
je me demande si repas confusion quand
même entre le fait de d'ouvrir les
frontières à l'importation des produits
ça bien entendu la communauté européenne
nous nous obligerait à le faire si on
prenait des décisions sociaux dans
certaines possibilités d'accord ne vois
pas qu'est ce qui fait qu est-ce qui
peut s'opposer à ce qu'ils année qui
tache claire qui disent la réalité des
choses et je vois pas en quoi
honnêtement la communauté européenne et
je voudrais voir le tête je vous cache
pas que sur lequel s'appuie pour dire il
est interdit de faire un étiquetage de
ceci ou de cela si vous le dites je ne
crois mais mais je manque quand même
j'étais récemment à bruxelles pour
d'autres considérations et j'ai vu que
le temps en temps il y avait une
interprétation donc j'aimerais bien
avoir ce texte
et si jamais il y avait une opportunité
peut-être qu en commission mixte
paritaire
on pourrait le revoir ceux ci étant ceux
venus bien entendu j'ai entendu entre
appel il est retiré le seul ministre
demande ira au sénateur revêt que dans
l'état actuel de la législation
européenne
l'objet qu'il vise ne peut pas être
obligatoire mais c'est tout le sens de
l'action qui est menée qui a été
rappelée à l'instant par le président et
maureen et qui est mené par bruno le
maire effectivement c'est de faire
évoluer et donc pour répondre très
directement à sa votre préoccupation le
ministère de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture va vous communiquer le
texte de façon à ce que vous ayez
justement tous les éléments je profite
de l'occasion pour dire qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire de
demandait tout à l'heure alain vasselle
moi je crois que ce qu'on peut faire
c'est relayé la la la la volonté du
gouvernement auprès des autres pays par
l'intermédiaire de la commission
européenne par l'intermédiaire des
contacts qui peut y avoir entre le
parlement européen et nos tours
parlement national pour faire avancer le
débat dans le sang ce qui vous préoccupe
bien alors le 30 rectifié bis et retirer
le 60e président est il possible que
l'on reprenne cet amendement en
modifiant légèrement la dernière partie
de la phrase il serait rectifier alors
il faudrait que la rectification soit
très légère pour cela puisse être
simplement faire disparaître ainsi que
l'indication du pays où il a été
fabriqué c'est la seule partie qui à mon
avis risque d'être en opposition avec
les indications européenne tant ce que
ça reste sur le territoire national
transformation sur le territoire
national rien ne nous empêche d'obliger
d'avoir
la précision de l'origine du produit
bien alors à vie de monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement qui
devient le 30 rectifié tient pas et est
un pas parce que il est important qu'on
puisse faire figurer je demande sur
l'étiquetage que nous voulons rendre
très incitatif pas obligatoire c'est pas
possible mais au moins très incitatif
dans l'intérêt et les producteurs des
transformateurs et des consommateurs je
pense que c'est important
il faut donc que cet étiquetage soient
clairs et qu'ils soient pas au taquet
par l'europe bien évidemment mais il
faut quand même qu'à un moment donné
l'europe se plie aussi aux décisions que
nous voulons prendre notre pays et
surtout devant le temps le mans alors
didier guillaume pardon monsieur le
ministre
rectification sur la rectification le
gouvernement ne peut pas y être
favorable parce que c'est justement ce à
quoi s'est livrée la grèce et qui a
justifié les poursuites qui ont été
engagées à son encontre par l'europe
voilà donc ça n'est pas possible dans
l'état actuel des choses madame suis
désolé de vous le dire
guillaume un monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je crois qu'on s'arrête un peu
longuement sur cet amendement on passera
plus vite sur d'autres mais je crois
qu'il est un peu fondamental dans la
discussion boutique que nous avons si
chaque fois que le parlement veut
prendre une décision on vous dit que
c'est pas possible parce que l'europe ne
sera pas d'accord alors autant tous
transférés à bruxelles excusez moi
d'être un brin caricatural et puis de
dire bas à bruxelles ils géreront le
droit français le droit espagnol le
droit italien
c'est ça le débat déjà qu' il va falloir
maintenant donner nos budgets
des nations avant pour que on imprime à
tour européenne je pense que ça ça ne va
pas deuxièmement nous pouvons comprendre
ce que dit le ministre par rapport aux
contraintes européennes
mais justement le parlement français
ferait un acte fort de voter cet
amendement pour soutenir le ministre
et pour dire ben justement on va faire
plier parce que j'entends les 10 q les
discours du président de la république
du gouvernement on ne se fera pas imposé
par l'europe il faut faire plier
l'europe
vous l'avez encore dit monsieur le
ministre il faut faire plier l'europe il
faut avancer mais pour l'instant ce que
l'on constate c'est qu'elle ne plie pas
vraiment l'europe et le fonds de se le
font de cet amendement n'est pas inquiet
pas de notre fait en plus quel est il
il est tout simplement de donner une
meilleure information aux consommateurs
on est dans l'article 1er du titre 1 de
cette loi sur la politique de
l'alimentation le ministre hier tous les
orateurs de tous les groupes d'ailleurs
on vantait le fait que pour la première
fois dans une loi en mettez en place
l'alimentation et mettre en place une
vraie politique de l'alimentation
monsieur le rapporteur tout à l'heure
vous saluer l'engagement de notre
collègue madame dumas pour tout ce
qu'elle fait dans cette direction
eh bien nous il nous semble que c'est le
moment là c'est pas politique c'est pas
politicien ses transversales n'y a pas
de problème chandre vais la retirer on
voit bien qu'ils il doit le retirer
pourquoi nous voulons le reprendre de
façon symbolique et cet amendement
peut-être sera-t-il rejetée mais si à un
moment ou un autre nous ne disons pas
clairement ici que nous voulons mettre
plus en plus avant la souveraineté des
états et la souveraineté du parlement
que nous voulons que l'étiquetage soit
le plus clair possible afin que le
consommateur sache à quoi s'en tenir et
il est important de voir l'origine de
ces produits alors on fera sûrement la
loi sera votée mais elle ce sera un peu
à l'eau tiède il nous semble et que
cette serait un acte fort et le
parlement sont au regret de le faire
dans cette direction c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous le
reprenons je sais pas si les rectifier
ou pas rectifié peut être odette
herviaux indiquera la rectification de
façon plus précise
mais ce débat là vraiment monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur rapporteur c'est un
débat important pour l'agriculture
française pour la politique de
l'alimentation et pour les consommateurs
alors jacques muller oui donc dans le
même état d'esprit je je m'interroge sur
là la réponse qui nous a été donnée par
par le ministre puisque l'union
européenne veille au respect de la
concurrence libre et non faussée entre
les états en l'occurrence l'amendement
tel qu'il a été rectifié porte sur ce
que nous faisons sur notre propre
territoire et donc de mon point de vue
la réponse qui m'a été donné ne me
satisfait pas la deuxième observation
que je voudrais faire c'est de revenir
un petit peu sur l'histoire lorsque la
colla politique agricole commune s'est
construite en 60 62 elle s'est
construite sur ce que la france avait
mis en place dans les années 50 les prix
indicatifs les prix d'intervention sur
les marchés du blé
quels qu'ils ont été instituées dans
l'est dans la pâte de 60,2 mais nous les
avions en france dans les années 50
autrement dit c'est ce que nous avions
fait chez nous qui s'est généralisé
ensuite ce que nous avions réussi chez
nous a été généralisée alors aujourd'hui
nous prenons une disposition qui est
fait quand même sur le fond unanimité
et finalement il faudrait attendre ce
que pense l'europe d'une éventuelle
décision
moi je crois qu'il faut prendre la
décision maintenant elle est bonne pour
nos producteurs
nous ne visons pas la concurrence des
pays étrangers et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous propose de voter cet
amendement alors
monsieur le président jean paul emorine
j'ai bien entendu jacques muller et
didier guillaume reconnu ce débat ce que
nous propose didier guillaume c'est
assez dangereux que quand on regarde par
le passé dès que le gouvernement
français s'est mis en infraction il ait
eu à payer des pénalités ou à rembourser
des aides qui ont été versées à tort
jacques aujourd'hui le débat que nous
avons est un état débat sur un genre
mais si charles revêt d'avoir posé cette
question c'est quand on a ces éléments
depuis le début de notre débat mais moi
je suis un européen convaincu
j'ai envie que l'europe avance le
président de la république l'a dit
l'autre jour l'europe nous appartient
mais il faut bien faire partager nos
points de vue si nous voulons avancer
c'est pas le tout via les deux avec une
idéologie bien spécifiques
si personne n'a partage nous prenons pas
faire l'avancé d'europe donc moi je moi
je
je suis contre l'amendement même
rectifié pas ce qui l'intéresserait que
les produits français mais on a de quoi
les ailes les pays étrangers et les
produits étrangers ne s'est pas
identifié
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
rester dans la directive européenne
et puis s'appuyer sur les capacités de
notre ministre de l'agriculture comme de
notre président de la république parce
que j'entends des critiques qui sont
faites par rapport au président de la
république qui va se déplacer pour
parler des relations commerciales avec
la grande distribution
regardez notre histoire chercher un
président de la république qui
s'intéressent à l'agriculture et qui va
défendre nos produits sur le terrain
bien aller donc c'est voler je vous
propose qu'on votre sur l'amendement 30
rectifié terre qui a été repris par
odette herviaux nous avons deux avis
défavorables qui est pour adopter cet
amendement qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le soir le 78e
rectifié rectifié tombe n'est pas
soutenu le 93 c'est odette herviaux non
c'est claude bérit débat
allez merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre comment l'a déjà vu
notamment
hier soir le conseil national de
l'alimentation a un rôle important à
jouer dans la définition de la politique
de l'alimentation du gouvernement or
cette instance indépendante qui regroupe
des collèges représentant les
consommateurs les industriels les
producteurs et la grande distribution
existe depuis 1985
depuis le début elle a pour mission de
donner des avis et recommandations aux
trois ministères compétents justement
sur la définition de la politique de
l'alimentation
l'adaptation de la consommation aux
besoins nutritionnels la sécurité et la
qualité des aliments l'information des
consommateurs
cette instance at elle atteint ses
objectifs
on peut penser que non puisque l'étude
d'impact qui est joint à la présente loi
montre clairement fait clairement le
constat d'une absence de politique
publique de l'alimentation en france
comment conférer plus de porter à ses
avis et à ses recommandations
est ce seulement une question de volonté
politique
le gouvernement a prévu de renforcer les
missions du sel n'a par voie
réglementaire et de l'élargir aux
associations de protection de
l'environnement
est-ce que c'est suffisant nous vous
proposons dans cet amendement de
consacré l'existence du sel n'a dans la
loi et dans le code rural
après la définition de la politique de
l'alimentation que vous avez souhaité y
intégrer comme pour l'observatoire
nous pensons qu'une instance même
consultative a plus de poids quand on la
reconnaît officiellement dans la loi
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
même hier soir vouloir faire du scène
un parlement de l'alimentation
régulièrement consultés par le
gouvernement
convenait que l'existence d'un tel
parlement n'est pas de l'ordre du
réglementaire c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons d'intégrer dont après la linea
le texte de l'amendement que je viens de
commenter merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le président monsieur bérit
débat le conseil national alimentation
est régie par les articles des 541 et
suivants du code de la consommation aux
à-coups proposé avec vos collègues de
transposer dans la loi les missions
prévues par ces articles et de manière
un peu moins précise sa composition
j'ai été tentée en tant que rapporteur
de faire la même chose mais il ya gergy
renoncé considérant que les règles
applicables aux organismes consultatifs
relever plutôt monsieur le ministre du
domaine réglementaire
par ailleurs la commission a précisé
dans un texte que le conseil national